welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm really excited
to be joined by elissa daugherty who is
the head
of sharla and the southeast recruitment
team at faden international
elissa has worked in the industry for
seven years and started her recruitment
career in 2014 working under the selby
jennings brand within the fading group
after that working in this team she
ended up becoming the account director
of their extremely successful preferred
partnership program
part of the business where they would
deliver an elite level of account
management service for faden's
top clients globally then alissa went on
and for the last three years has been
responsible for the growth
of the charla and southeast region where
she has grown it from scratch
with two others to currently 35 heads
in that part of the business so alyssa
thank you so much for joining me on the
podcast
yeah thanks for having me thanks for the
introduction really looking forward to
this
i think you've been on a really
interesting journey so where we always
like to start
is in your opinion what characteristics
and traits do you think make up a highly
successful
recruitment consultant yeah absolutely
so
this is the question i get asked a lot
right now as we're growing i think every
candidate i interview at the moment asks
me this question it's really fair
question i think it's an important one
so
for me it probably won't be an entirely
unique answer but i'll say
it centers around kind of two components
i think the first is mindset
um i think mindset there's sort of two
types of people in my view i think there
are people that have
you know sort of limiting or defeatist
mindsets and then i think there are
people that have pretty
optimistic anything can happen i'm just
gonna get it done mindsets and
i think if you are in recruitment it's
really difficult to be successful with
the first
i think that you know it's very easy to
be someone that says
this is hard this is difficult it's
impossible you know it's just not gonna
happen
um or get really down on yourself on a
bad day and and just
not think that there is kind of the
opportunity to
to excel in in the way that there really
is in the industry so
for me i think you have to be someone
that looks at a situation
and sees the ability to do it i think
you have to be
much more of a yes person than a no
person and i think
if you are that individual then that
means inherently
you're pretty driven and you're pretty
optimistic and i think
you'll inherently then kind of be
successful in the business i think
there's there's really
nothing you can't achieve in recruitment
you know there's no sort of like
magic skill set that someone has over
anyone else so so really it does just
come down in my mind to mindset
and i think the second thing is
intellectual curiosity
um for me when i first started
recruiting i remember my manager said to
me
um you know you don't have to understand
your space you just need to be able to
recruit right and and i think for me
starting off
that worked quite well because it taught
me the psychology of recruitment i had
to really understand like the heart and
core of what motivated people
how to influence people but i don't
think it made me
much value to them and advising them on
some of the moves that they made so i
think
where i really began to kind of take off
in my careers when i
made the decision on my own to seek out
those extra levels
of advice right and and i think whether
that is
reading a book or listening to a podcast
like this or you know
seeking out a a mentor in the business
whatever it may be
you know i tell my guys all the time
like your job is to grow a network of
experts in this industry
how often do you just call them and say
hey can you explain this to me
can you talk to me more about what you
do here and i think far too often people
just don't right
um and so for me i think if you're if
you're someone that has those two things
at the core
then you know those are the people that
find the next level of success and
recruitment
i love that so what i just wanted to get
your thoughts on really quickly
is the first part of that around the
mindset piece yeah
because what you're touching on there
that type of mindset i feel like you're
talking a bit about
this sort of carol dweck growth mindset
that a lot of people
have mentioned before obviously
resilience is it now i feel like you're
talking about
that ability to sort of i guess look at
things in a
in a positive light to say hey what can
i learn from that rather than like
pointing the finger and going this
happened because of that i'm not taking
responsibility
so the question i want to ask you
because we recently had an event on this
which i thought was
really interesting is basically do you
believe that mindset can be learned
or trained or do we already possess it
it's a good question i've i've
definitely heard the debate on both
sides
um i think where i fall is this isn't
going to be a great answer for you but
like somewhere in the middle
yeah i think there are absolutely some
people that are just
bred with a more optimistic mindset i
mean i don't think they're necessarily
born with it i think it has a lot to do
with the environment that you come up in
um but i think once you kind of are
established as an adult can you train
yourself to be better at this 100
i mean i think there are a lot of
exercises and mental toughness
and optimism that you know help really
successful people kind of reach those
next levels of their careers and
and i think yeah like why not try in my
view
i think i've seen a lot of people that i
know personally make pretty major
transformations in this
and honestly i think i'm probably one of
them like
i grew up a bit of a perfectionist i
think i had a really
specific mindset um and when
things went wrong i had a really tough
time with it and and
through a series of things i think i was
able to kind of push away from that and
learn how to adapt from it and actually
see pieces of it as a strength so
i absolutely think it's something that
can be you know trained and influenced
but i think growing up in an environment
where
you're exposed to that is helpful as
well yeah
so where i want to start then is just
understanding a bit about
one sort of how was your first year in
recruitment
and sort of what did maybe did you learn
what do you find challenging but
i don't know sort of exactly how the
what the typical stories are in the u.s
but typically in the uk people will say
i fell into recruitment
right now sort of having
met and interviewed more and more
recruiters that either go from the uk
market to the us market or
based in the us what what sort of uk
recruiter definitely typically find is
that
sort of working as a recruiter in the us
is typically like the the reputation of
recruiters in the us
definitely isn't as tarnished or bad as
it is in the uk
don't know if you're aware of this do
you know that obviously yeah
yeah so i guess i'll just interested
like obviously i can see that
you um or she graduated at university of
michigan like how did you end up in
recruitment was it an accident
was it actually something that i don't
know like you was actually like quite
motivated to get into just curious as to
like how did
how did you end up in recruitment yeah
it's a fair question
um i definitely didn't intend to end up
in recruitment so
i kind of fell into it um i was actually
pre-med
in undergrad and i really decided
right before i graduated that i didn't
want to go to medical school because i
wanted
money um sooner than the next 10 years
of my life so
that was a big part of the decision for
me um and i think
how did i end up in recruitment
specifically um
i think at the time honestly it wasn't
nearly as common as it is now like i
hear a lot of people
you know say they're in recruitment now
i think in the us it's spoken about a
lot more as a career path than it ever
was when i was in school i had never
heard of it
and i really just had someone branch
like how to say to me i think this is
something that you should take a look at
um i had studied you know psychology a
lot in school i find it
intrinsic motivations you know really
interesting so
um yeah i sort of just started to
explore it a little bit
and i actually i hadn't heard of faded
or replied to fade and um i was really
fortunate that faden reached out to me
and and i did just kind of fall into
them as a company
um but i was looking at you know kind of
some similar roles so
yeah that's sort of how it happened for
me okay so just on this point really
quickly just to get your honest thoughts
uh recently been recording like a sort
of entry-level graduate
focus series and obviously
i guess i just wanted to sort of hear
how you dealt with or if you did have to
deal with
see i can imagine particularly if you
were going down the medical route that
friends peers family were like oh my god
the list of what you're doing
like like i don't know because and then
you ended up in recruitment they might
be like what you was training to be
in medicine or whatever it may be like
how did because i'm sure
there'll be people that end up in
recruitment and i don't know may end up
feeling
guilty as part or like oh they were
meant to do this or whatever i think it
could be a really challenging time right
so i don't know did you have to deal
with any of
that like alyssa what are you doing and
how did you deal with that
uh yeah a little bit i think um you know
i went to a
relatively prestigious school a lot of
my friends were going into like pretty
prestigious jobs
i was definitely the only one that went
into recruitment um
i think people just at that point
honestly didn't know that much about it
so
i didn't get a lot of like negative
connotation associated yeah
i was also fortunate both of my parents
were in sales the majority of my life
i had a lot of support at home that i
was going into a commission job that
they just sort of saw as sales and
an opportunity to kind of excel so um i
don't think that that's something i came
up against that much fortunately but i i
definitely
can understand you know going home and
telling your parents who want to be
yeah it's like what yeah so look
obviously work to
obviously selby jennings which is one of
the the brands under
um and yeah and one of the sort of faded
international brands so like
tortoises about i'm sure like you
communicate
some part of this however you
communicate to people you hire for your
business now on teams now but obviously
most people would describe
first two years in recruitment as bloody
hard
maybe even hardest parts of your working
life that you may ever face right so
always intrigued and i definitely
experienced that i went from being the
top sales person in
my sort of world before recruitment and
being bottom of the pack
so like what what how would you describe
your first year what did you find
difficult what were some of the things
that you really had to work through
yeah uh it's a really fair question i
actually talked to my team a lot about
this
um i took seven months to do my first
deal which was like wow
beyond average yeah so i had a really
tough first year
um and i think
probably there were two points where i
doubted whether or not this was
something i was cut out to to kind of do
um and that was what made it the hardest
you know when i was committed and all in
and just kind of had my head down and
was going
it was okay because those points are
kind of just was bought in and i believe
that it was going to come
it was really in those moments where it
felt like it wasn't coming that
i i kind of had um i guess just those
this real
questioning difficult like should i be
here should i not be here type of
conversations with myself and yeah
i think i'm grateful every day that i
had people around me at that point
really encourage me and push me and say
you know you're doing the right things
like
keep going and it will pay off and it's
a really cliche thing and recruitment
but like it 100
does like if you continue to put the
work and the time in you know that the
payoff is there and
i went on to to finish that year as our
top rookie um so yeah
after seven minutes yeah wow so what
just people want to know like what what
what changed like what time
did you corn like to uh turn sorry like
what
was it just things just started to fall
into place was it you had some sort of
epiphany moment so i was like oh
actually i've done that wrong a few
times now let me do this like
what what do you think besides obviously
helps that you've got people around you
saying hey keep doing that and i
definitely had that
from experienced people that helps
because you believe them they've
obviously seen a lot of people do what
you've done but like
what because i'm sure that there'll be
moments now that you've helped people
turn that corner and your own team's
like what
i don't know what changed yeah i think
it was two things i think
one was honestly yes a lot of the work
did just pay off
um i think i did one thing i did a
really good job at was really just
continuing to
put in the work i kind of made the
decision that i wanted to finish out the
year
having given it absolutely everything
that i had and that if at that point it
didn't work and i had to walk away
at least i knew i put everything i had
into the job and i could walk away
knowing
okay you know what i gave that what i
had to do yeah well i think
a lot of that started to come through
and hit you know there was a lot of like
playing the long game laying the
groundwork that did come through and
kind of those last couple months of the
year that
that really helped with the performance
but i think the other was really
choosing to kind of be a sponge which
again is a bit of a cliche
but i really just saw out it went to
every top performer in our business
constantly
and just was like how do you do this how
do you do that you know can i watch you
do this can i listen to this phone call
um i remember i would get like coffee
before work drinks after work with
people and just just
ask them and there were some things
where i would say
okay yeah like that's a really dumb idea
like i'm not gonna do that
but i think there were a lot of things
that i took
and implemented really well and and that
were really beneficial to me in my
career and
i always encourage my guys to do this
now because i think even if
you even if you don't hear something
where you say ah like i should be doing
that
at the very least it makes you think
differently about the way that you
recruit
when you understand how someone else
approaches it it
challenges you to kind of have to think
outside the box a little more and i
think for me
you know those were the two things that
really contributed to turning that
corner
i know so like people would probably
really want me to go practical here
okay so thinking of those conversations
that's what this is all about right so i
guess one or two things come to mind
where maybe it was like oh oh my god why
didn't i know that before i'm gonna now
do that i don't know one or two things
that
maybe stuck with you where you that you
felt had a really impact on your
performance might have been on the
client side can they decide
what comes up for you yeah i think one
um huge one for me was to know the worth
of my time
um and to value my time i think that
i had some conversation with one of my
mentors along the lines of like
if you had no base salary and had to
just put time into
you know places where you knew you were
going to get paid would you be putting
your time where you are now
i think that was a huge moment for me um
where the answer was no
i think i was putting time into clients
that weren't as committed
i think i was putting time into
candidates that weren't that interested
and really trying to just kind of force
things to happen
and i came to really learn i think
throughout that process as well from a
business development and a client
management perspective that
you know how you
a client's going to treat you the way
that you dictate right like if you
don't give me feedback and you don't
call me back and you just answer an
email with one line
like and i keep sending you good people
why are you
gonna not do that right like of course
you're just gonna continue to do what
you do because i'm giving you what you
want anyway
um so i think i i really learned to say
no i learned to
stop working on things and actually in
turn it led to clients coming back to me
and saying hey you know why aren't you
sending us people and
opened the door for me to have those
conversations and really say
you know you haven't given me feedback
or what you're looking for doesn't exist
like here's what i'm seeing in the
market where can you be flexible
and really just facilitate more of that
advisory and consultative
piece of recruitment that i think i was
just sort of missing before
i love that thanks for sharing that yeah
yeah i think
the more experience you get the more you
definitely get
you just really value your time and i
think that's definitely yeah you can
learn that the hard way
at the beginning so again this may seem
really
this may seem like really basic to you
but i think sometimes
people just really want to hear this
stuff like when you approach top
performers in your business
like how how did you approach that
conversation was it just as simple as
like hey
i can see you're typically always high
in the leaderboards or like i don't know
like was it was like
i'd love to pick your brain like i don't
know how did you approach that
conversation out of interest
was it as simple as that um i think
at the time in new york our team was
quite small so that whole
lot um you know there was a lot of
openness
usually i've always found it's best to
approach people over a drink
if you can or like in a social setting
um
honestly because i think people are just
more comfortable and they're more honest
um like i think when you approach
someone like and go sit in a meeting
room in a formal setting like they may
give you good advice but
it's not necessarily going to be as
candid or as like raw and and those were
the conversations i took the most out of
like i wanted people to be blunt with me
i wanted people to give me criticism
um so i think that was that was one
thing i really tried to do was do it
outside of work whether that was coffee
nice after um and yeah i think the other
was
honestly just flattery like when i was
people outside of new york i think it
was just very like hey you know you're
doing a great job with x y and z like
i'd love to learn a little bit more
about your approach on this and
it was nerve-wracking every time you
press send on the email or like picked
up the phone to dial someone
um especially when i was like a nobody
who was absolutely failing
um but i think in recruitment like
a people like to talk about themselves
generally so like they're almost
always going to take that phone call um
and b
i think you know it is a pretty
collaborative competitive environment
right so like
if you're succeeding you do want to be
able to kind of share that with other
people and help them so i've i've never
had
anyone you know kind of not come back to
me or not be open to having that
conversation
yeah awesome because i think sometimes
yeah people that
yeah being worried about i don't know
maybe looking silly or
like yeah like then maybe reacting like
what are you gonna take all my secrets i
don't know so yeah
that's what i wanted to ask that i'm
just gonna say i think there's like a
tremendous amount of respect
that i give to people who have the
courage to do that
yeah like it takes a lot of balls to put
yourself out there to someone who like
is a top performer
when you're absolutely no one and i i
think
most people in recruitment would respect
that but that's why yeah
i know i i agree and i think speaking to
a lot of
i'm spending a lot more time now
speaking to
um recruitment business owners that are
growing their
businesses and they want they like they
love to see
people in their business like spend time
in their own development and that's what
that that's what you would be doing by
doing that you're showing your own
initiative
you haven't been asked to do that your
manager hasn't gone have you thought
about reaching out to that person
and there's nothing more great and i'm
sure you've seen this in your people now
i'm sure that just fills you with joy or
excitement like wow
that's amazing that person did that off
their own back and
too right that's i think that's such a
good sign i think
100 and i totally agree yeah so
let's so what what happened just really
quickly then like obviously you ended up
being rookie of the year
did you obviously you then obviously got
that accolade did you find it hard to
then
back up the second year was it sort of
smooth sailing was there any sort of
main challenges you had in the second
year or what did the second year look
like
yeah um so i went through a good period
of kind of
performing well and then i i went
through a good period of blanking for a
while which was really tough
i think i say this to my team a lot
absolutely everyone hits a low in
recruitment it doesn't matter how good
you are how much you've learned
um you're always going to have a period
where it sucks and it feels like
nothing's happening
um so i definitely hit that and you know
that was
i think something i was better prepared
for after having sort of the initial
journey that i had
in the business um and then yeah you
know honestly
i was really lucky i did really well the
second half of the year
um i ended up closing one of the largest
deals at that time it was the largest
deal we had done so yeah
how large was it i was around 4
40 i think oh wow that's big
yeah yeah so obviously so basically i'm
sure you should say to
everyone like i bet people were like
elissa what are you doing in that first
half of the year
like i love that yes no it's a fair
question i mean
the holidays are slow
um so i guess just i i really want to
ask because everyone goes through this
and i think it's so
important for people to hear this from
other like it's it's easier for you to
in hindsight to go
like oh i ended up like doing like
creating i have some good milestones
achievements but
in those moments it's so hard to like
see the light at the end of the tunnel
so like and i'm sure you help your team
with this now but like
i don't know if i'm listening right now
and i'm going through that where i
haven't done the deal for a while
i'm struggling to see that like the end
of the tunnel like what would you be
saying to me like what should i what
sort of helped you
push through those low moments that
obviously we all face in in recruitment
go back to basics and work to a day plan
i think
that every single top performer
that falls off it it happens because
they just stopped doing the little
things that make them successful and i
i adamantly believe that um i sit down
with people all the time
and it could be that they're having
trouble pulling jobs and they say you
know
we look i'm like cool how is she
following up they're like
not really that much right like i think
there's always
something there and i think recruitment
is a bit of a science i think it does
come back to the numbers like you know
what you need to do to be successful
if you're not putting enough out there
for good things to come back to you then
inherently you're not going to do as
well
right like it's about having as many
opportunities to succeed as possible so
if you've stopped sending as many
handheld messages if you've stopped
sending bd emails the way that you
should if you've stopped just picking up
the phone and trying to call clients
um you've stopped you know adding new
contacts to
your system and growing your network
like people do
that all the time right it's really easy
to get focused on just one aspect of
what we do and kind of lose the rest and
so that would be my advice go back to
the basics call candidates
pull leads understand what's happening
in your market get some intel
find places to target and build from
there love that
yeah you hear i was going to ask you
like in your view like what does
like the basics mean but i think you
just sort of categorize them there
yeah just so people people love finding
out so you mentioned day plans there
i'm glad you did yeah so something that
i'm finding
definitely um obviously supporting and
speaking more and more
to more and more recruiters around where
they want to develop where their gaps
are with
the recruitment mentors platform so we
can go and create that content
like we recently added a learning area
called productivity and time management
and look my view on this is like if i
think when i was in recruitment
most people would i'd like to think most
people would not say that they had some
sort of time management
training or like i don't know like i
just you just had to work out as it were
like i used to just
trying something like i used to i was
only in the office of like eight people
the person i sat next to we did we had
our own patch but sometimes we'll cross
over
so like i would just try and come in
either a bit before that she does so i
could get straight onto things
like that and then i would just like
i'll just try and like
see what other people were doing but
like and we would
sometimes have like some weeks we would
do our sort of 10 to 12 tuesday and
thursday
we'd all be doing bd at the same time
but like you learn as you go on like
time management basically yeah i think
you just yeah so
like you said there's a bit of a science
so i guess the question i have for you
and i know there's nuances here and
everyone's different
but like what does a typical good day
structure look like for you like i don't
know what what comes up for you when i
say that out of interest
for me or for a recruitment consultant
because i guess it's a little different
now for me yeah for you now a few now
it's different but i guess if you're
like clearly you're supporting your team
with yeah
doing the basics having a plan like i
guess
if you if i was to say to you if a
recruiter right now and your team is
like doing the basics really well
they're performing and they've got a
good structure they've got a good
routine
what do you what how would you describe
their typical routine would you say
i think uh you want it like broken down
by activity i'm assuming that yeah let's
do it let's list it from
8am they're doing this probably just
because that people like people love
this yeah so i tell most of my
recruiters to
start with a 50 50 split between
business development and candidate
oriented activity and then lean one way
or the other depending on their current
situation right
depending on the pipeline of jobs that
you have to service how well you're
servicing them currently and whatever it
may be but i think that 50 50 split is
always where you should start
um i think one of the most important
things to do to be
truly productive and efficient with your
day is to make your day plan achievable
and i think it's also to build in
administrative time
so there's inherently always things that
come into your day that completely throw
off a day plan and when you're booking
hour by hour
that can be really frustrating um so i
i really recommend that our guys come in
and they either come in a few minutes
early or they spend
you know kind of the first 15 to 30
minutes really clearing their inbox you
know getting
any messages answered that need to be
answered just all of the administrative
stuff right um and then i i recommend
that happening
straight after lunch and then at the end
of the day as well so i almost always
say block off at least 30 minutes in
those three windows
um just to kind of account for random
things and
so it's a button but then in between
there are you typically
obviously emergency stuff or things you
have to get sorted you would but
like are you then encouraging or the
best people will ignore
out of those times they're ignoring
their email they're not going to reply
straight away to stuff unless it's
urgent
yes discipline on that yeah yeah 100 i
mean i've
i've gone so far as to like turn off
notifications for people
when emails come in i think um it can be
really distracting like your calendar
popping up every five minutes of your
email popping up
um you know every time someone applies
into an ad you get a notification things
like that so yeah you really have to
i think especially early train yourself
to stay focused on the task that you're
in
and i think the way that you do that and
stay organized is you can have those
random thoughts
like oh but i need to do this or that
write it down like and that's why i said
that that's all
your heads when it comes into your head
write it down and then you'll deal with
it at the end of the day you'll put it
on your plane for the next day or finish
it before that day when it's done so
um yeah i think from that point forward
you know we really focus
kind of the the first two to three hours
of the morning on canada oriented
activities so we'll get through
um you know as many calls as we can
we'll really try to put
enough out there for people to come back
to us throughout the day so that may be
head hunting maybe ad response
may just be going through clear lists
things like that um
and then usually before and like kind of
the hour before lunch we'll try to do a
business development oriented activity
for for that last hour of the morning
and sometimes that's just kind of
hammering the phones on something you
know sometimes that's
uh sending out a targeted email or
whatever it may be
and and then we'll we'll break the
afternoon then again kind of between the
two
so really looking at uh drilling into
working some jobs pretty hard getting
your clears getting candidates out the
door
and then doing both short game and kind
of long game oriented business
development you know that's
i think one of my biggest theories on
business development is you have to make
sure you're
you're mixing it up a lot so just making
sure that they're balancing kind of
volume
oriented activities with targeted and
then pushing through that way
so would you define short-term and
long-term business development approach
maybe a short-term
one would be i've seen this client
they're in my patch
they've got live jobs i've got
candidates i'm going to be following up
i'll be approaching them
and then long term would be a bit more
maybe you you would have done some sort
of mapping exercise maybe the beginning
of the year
or something you're always doing what
companies would i love to work for who's
on our dream
customer list and then there's maybe
different touch points you're trying to
create with them is that fair yeah i
know 100 i think that's really fair
um i think also yeah
i think you hit the on the head right
like chasing a hot lead something you
know is active like that's an immediate
potential short-term win
um but i think also just balancing like
sending out a really active candidate
with
sending out an article that someone
might find interesting
people get their thoughts on right i
think it's just creating different
dynamics to have different types of
conversations like don't just always go
in and ask someone like are you hiring
right now because if they're not you're
like eliminating the opportunity to
build that relationship for the future
so i think that that kind of
yeah as well love that so
thank you for going into that people
love this so like the key things i take
away from there
is make time so if you have a day plan
and you listen to this great but how in
your day plan have you got time to do
your administrative tasks if you don't
add them and i couldn't agree more that
with you when i put like bd sessions in
my diary
like the last half an hour of that is
then like doing the email follow-up
doing all the admin stuff
and try and be the self-disciplined as
you said like we're getting pinged
notifications left right and center so
if if you if you are susceptible to them
then sort of try and
set up your environment to win right
yeah and then the other thing
to force on this this has been a game
changer for me but like would you say
most recruiters that are good at this
and have this structure disciplined
would they typically without leaving
would they plan their day beforehand
before leaving the office typically
yes yeah yeah like that's game changer
if you're not if your listeners you
don't do that
like before you leave the office do a
to-do list understand what you're doing
the following day
you will sleep better you won't be
thinking about work when you get home as
much
and there's not a better feeling than
going into work going i know what i need
to focus on today and there's nothing
more worse
than going and going right what am i
what am i focusing on today
so i'm glad you said that yeah okay okay
so let's sort of take this to
well i want to talk about how you've
been growing the team leadership these
types of things but
let's just talk about your journey on
the account
management side obviously you then
became obviously you as an account
director for the preferred partnership
program
so would you mind very quickly just i
guess just given us a bit of a snapshot
on the purpose of
the preferred partnership program and
then i'm really keen to talk to you
around
i guess how recruiters listen to this
can get better at
building relationships being more
strategic in the accounts that they can
expand
these types of things but could you just
give us a bit of a snapshot on that
yeah 100 so um the
kind of development of the partnership
program and what it came out of was
really the desire to
increase the level of service for our
top clients kind of globally across the
business
to increase the synergy or the the way
that we were leveraging the opportunity
to do business with those clients across
all of our teams and our brands
um and and every office kind of
nationally and internationally as well
where there was scope to do so
um and then looking at just kind of
consistent
streams of revenue right like for you
know our
our leadership team for our investors
whoever it may be like a huge thing is
being able to say consistently we can
rely on x amount of business from these
partners etcetera so that was a big part
kind of the strategy as well
um in terms of how we worked and what we
did i think we
we really looked at identifying you know
what made a good client what made a
client someone we could work with
well where did we see the opportunity to
really grow
um within kind of that client from what
we were doing and i guess as an example
you know there were a number of clients
that we worked with in just
one small area of our business and maybe
we were doing a lot of business with
them you know maybe
we were doing a lot in just technology
right or even one arm of technology
within a company
but we had you know tons of other teams
that could be servicing that client from
other angles and other locations and
geographies so
um we really spent a lot of time
strategically identifying how can we
a obviously perform to the level that
people want to go in and advocate for us
and recommend us
and kind of push us forward internally
um but be like how can we then
you know get people to do that for us
right how can we have the right types of
partnerships build the right types of
trust with clients
them know that we will go above and
beyond to get things done for them
that they'll you know kind of put their
neck on and advocate for us internally
to have more opportunity to work with
them in other areas so
that was kind of the overall goal of the
team that we did
i love it so can we unpack this a bit
because i think people
people want to know how they can achieve
that right because i think
it's very easy to like as a as you're
growing a recruitment business or like
have different teams where
yeah you have different disciplines
let's say because obviously what what
are the different disciplines that you
have within
fade in is it finance is it finance or
not finance tech
yes so we have financial services life
sciences um
kind of a renewable energy and
infrastructure team
a technology team but they focus mainly
outside of financial services
and then we have a team that focuses on
end-to-end supply chain recruitment so
um even when i'm talking about the the
leveraging
it sally jennings for us breaks down
into you know six seven areas so
it was even that minuscule and then
macro brand brand
yeah yeah so because like i think it's
really easy to assume like
we've got the ex-client that's working
with salvage endings and this team
yeah and we know that they have jobs or
other parts of the business that the
supply chain team could support
yeah it just it would just make sense to
you to go yeah so we'll hire
we've got this technology team i've got
a supply chain recruiter here that's got
a good track record let's bring them in
and they can start leveraging the
clients we've been working but
it's not as easy as that it never
normally
works that way you know it's a lot more
harder to do so i guess
what i'm keen to first so two things i
really want to get your thoughts on
before we
move on to the next part of your journey
is one what you found to be
the best possible way of like expanding
those accounts and then getting more
teams supporting that one client so it
seemed like from what you shared
it was people just going hey these guys
have done a great job with us i wanted
to connect you with them
it seemed like a bit of that going on
and then the other thing that i wanted
to get your thoughts on
was then like how what was your sort of
grading system or what did a good client
look like
i think a lot of recruits can benefit
from that right now because a lot of
people have a lot of jobs and it's
really transitions to candidates short
so they have to get really good at
understanding what
is a good client yeah the first thing
like what ended up being like the
i know there'll be a lot of nuance to
this but like what was the recipe would
you say to
taking a client that was just using one
part of the business to then
expanded potentially using two three
four different parts of the business
and serving that what was the recipe the
typical recipe for that to work
yeah i think there are a few things but
i think at the core of all of it and
maybe i'll give a little bit of
backstory to this to sort of explain
where the strategy came from
um when i first took on that role i
spent a lot of time in my first few
months
speaking with existing clients of ours
and really understanding like how did
they view us
um how much value to be added to their
business were we their go-to recruitment
firm why or why not
and i think pretty consistently a
message i found across the board is that
we were
you know one of the best if not the best
at what we did in the areas we were
operating in
we were pretty consistent in being able
to execute and fill positions that we
were given
but we weren't that pleasant to work
with um and i think
that was off the back of a few things
but one of which was just we were
we were aggressive we were new to the
market we were trying to build something
from nothing
and so we we did a lot of kind of
busting our way through doors and trying
to figure things out and that doesn't
always rub
you know people the best way so i think
we had to kind of take a step back and
make a really conscious effort to
understand like
how do we not just service you and
provide you the best talent but how do
we become
a true partner that you can work with in
a way that
doesn't cause you any headaches right
like how do i be that phone call you
want to make where even if we weren't
the best you're going to call me anyway
because you prefer working to us
over these other flies that maybe make
it really difficult so um
that was a huge thing so i guess from an
advice perspective what that translates
into for me is really taking the time to
understand
how a business works and operates like
what is their process internally who are
the decision makers
what can you do what can't you do where
can you kind of push the envelope a
little bit and where do you need to kind
of
hold back and respect boundaries that
they're drawing um
you know i think one thing we did really
well that that helped us
was actually playing by the rules right
i think we would go in and we'd say cool
like what can we do to show you
that we respect your process that we
want to be this partner right and
and then we do it for six months we come
back and be like cool what now like
now what do we get from it right and i
think there was a lot of
of that that went on you know people
asked us for things we reciprocated
i think also we tried to find ways to
add value
beyond just recruitment and beyond just
candidates
um you know we really took up diversity
and inclusion as a huge part of our
business and what we drive and how we
you know kind of offer um insight and
services and consulting to the clients
that we work with and i think that
really helped us as well you know that's
a huge
they find a pain point for almost every
organization across the globe right like
diversity and inclusion is one of them
so
i think just understanding how can i
offer you things that are going to be
useful to you and your business
without necessarily immediately
expecting something in return and i
think
that was our strategy and it built the
right type of
rapport and relationships within these
businesses so people started to
want to take our phone call to want to
call us back
and we sort of just chipped away at it a
bit there love that
and then and i don't know there'll be i
love the work so i think what i love
about that is
obviously as it can be quite scary right
to sort of
find out what you're not good at as a
business so like anyone listen to this
that
is able is willing to do that clearly
that then
can present amazing opportunities for
you to improve
yeah and yeah make sure that your
customers clients candidates are like
yeah having a great experience
so i love the fact that you did that and
we're willing to ask the difficult
questions
so after all that that all makes sense
was then was it obviously like you said
you were giving more than taking
respecting their processes making like
leaving a good impression
delivering all these sorts of things yes
was it obviously then that meant that
people were more willing to then put
their neck on the line because they've
experienced all of that but was was the
growth of these accounts and expanded
these accounts did it typically come
from hey listen you know you've been
doing a good job you know you said that
we've really improved or whatever
how happy would you be to introduce me
to x
like was that how it was that how it
typically grew like is that how it
worked typically
i was absolutely a part of how it grew
i would like to say like i wish it were
more of how we grew to be honest it was
a good portion and it was important but
i think
one of the challenges to that um from an
execution perspective
is that often internally within
organizations people don't actually know
who's covering what they don't actually
know the person that's sitting in that
of the team so they're not
that apt to reach out to someone that
they don't know make a recommendation
when they have no idea if they need a
recruiter or they you know if
they don't know what their pain point is
or have a relationship with them so
i think sometimes that was a big hurdle
and
how we got around that when we found it
was really then
reaching out and making those people
understand what our track record was and
the people that we did have
relationships with
and the work that we had done how we had
gone about doing it and and i think
we sort of at that point tried to let
our our work speak for itself to some
extent and also
just continue to encourage them to pick
up the phone and have a conversation
and then really it's just about that
first call right from that call you can
capitalize on that opportunity
hopefully nine times out of ten um if
you handle it the right way and kind of
go about it from from the right angles
so i think for us
it was you know the goal was always that
approach always to be introduced to to
have someone go advocate for us
and we absolutely have had that happen
which has been fantastic we're really
lucky to have clients that
have gone bad for us even even with
other clients sometimes um
but i would say there's an absolutely a
good portion of the time where like it's
just
it's just not logistically feasible for
that to happen all the time
um and so you know we we had to kind of
lean on on other things like that
that makes complete sense and i think i
guess a couple of things that come to
mind there
i guess yeah some good sort of mapping
out of the business
being strategic and then i guess maybe
sometimes it'd be a good idea and good
etiquette to say hey
you know we've been working together
i've seen that such and such
is in this part of business have no idea
if they're recruiting would you be
adverse me to reaching out to them like
maybe get permission sometimes but
i do really like that because if you're
proactive and you go hey alyssa that we
haven't spoken before
but we've been working with such and
such this is our track record this is
how we've helped them
i know they'd be happy to take a call if
you want to reference that would you be
able to
like yeah so like being proactive as
well as yeah i get what you mean there's
it's the missing context that sometimes
doesn't make the introduction work
doesn't it and yeah
yeah i love that so i think okay i think
it's very like don't ask don't get
like that's that's my message on this
stuff yeah so like why not
yeah yeah i love that so okay next thing
before we move on to the last bit then
like in your view then because i'm sure
this is what you like spent a lot of
time
understanding like what makes a good
client a good client in your point of
view because obviously
a typical there might be like typical
there might be some people listen to
have some sort of like
not grade the jobs that they have it
might be like i've got five grade a jobs
six grade b jobs et cetera and grade a
might be
a business that has agreed to work me
exclusively they call me back when they
say
these types of things grade b might be
we've got terms
they're a bit sketchy sometimes they
don't sort of come back to me they're a
bit slow they're not exclusive
but they give me a fair chance and then
group c might just be clients that
you're just prospecting i haven't really
built so much rapport with you're just
following up
like how do you have any sort of like
system that
you work too out of interest like what
what sort does a good client look like
from your perspective of interest
yeah i think they're two different
things i think there's what does a good
client look like and what does a good
job look like
um i think what does a good client look
like is
someone where we have access to key
stakeholders
i think it's really difficult to work
only through hr um
you have to even if you just start off
that way like before they're a good
client i think you have to earn the
right to be
pretty integrated with stakeholders in
the business and leaders and the hiring
managers you're working with otherwise
you know it's it's as great as hr can be
um they can also be
you know a little uh challenging at
times and so i think it's important that
for a client to truly be somewhere we're
going to dedicate a ton of time
we need to be going to the source and be
having intake calls and getting on you
know
vcs to talk about feedback and and
really be advising and understanding and
kind of
moving our process forward from there um
i think another is pretty basic our
terms
um you know what is our agreement with
you do we work to exclusivity
you know are we working at our standard
rates or we come down because you
you know won't go any higher and that's
what you work with other agencies at
um we typically to be honest
don't prioritize clients that are
working at least at least here for us we
don't prioritize clients and we know
we're working with a ton of other firms
like at the end of the day
there's more than enough business out
there to not spend time being one of
seven agencies on a position
so i don't think that that's the right
type of client
um and similar to that i think portals
fit into that right you talk about
you know i won't say the brand names but
like there are a couple you know portal
systems out there that companies
recruit through and um to us you know i
think unless that's coupled with
you know relationships and engagement
beyond that within the business you know
that doesn't make a great client either
um and then yeah
i think the last is really just looking
at the the overall
client as a whole is this the type of
company that we want to be working with
this is the type of opportunity we want
to be bringing to our candidates is this
somewhere that people
you know want to work and we get excited
about whether that's a big name or a
tiny name it has to be something that
we're passionate about and
and we back you know kind of what
they're doing and the the role that
they're playing in their industry in the
market
so um for me those are kind of the three
things that we look at
i think when you're looking at what
makes a good job you know we include
things like looking at you know this the
speed of obviously response the the size
of the candidate pool
um is a big one for me like we really
have to think about how much time is
going to go into this versus how many
candidates out there can actually do
this job
will want to do this job are qualified
for this job are in the compensation
range et cetera so
um i think there's a lot of other kind
of
dynamics that go into it when you're
figuring out how much time to spend
specifically on the job beyond
just kind of the client quality sure
no awesome thanks for sharing that
really yeah i think i think it's such an
important point to make is it's not all
about the client it's also like
yeah are you excited about their brand
are you in line with like what they're
trying yeah like
also think about is it something that
you're proud to
represent in the market and take to the
market and also think about those things
it's not just all about the client
um yeah love that so
as we come to the end here just keen to
talk a bit about your
journey on growing teams leadership
so i think it's a perfect place to ask
this obviously after you
obviously from that partnership role you
then decided with two other colleagues
to take on this journey of then growing
charlotte and the southeast
right brand new obviously opportunity or
obviously yeah new adventure
i asked ollie what would you what do you
want me to ask alyssa a question wise
i think this is the perfect place to ask
it and what he said what he said was
like he like why why have you always
been someone that's willing to like get
out of your comfort zone
and i think this is the perfect place to
ask it because you went from being a
recruiter
did that journey then obviously helped
sort of orchestrate and be involved with
this obviously new part of the business
and then now obviously growing and
leading the team which obviously
i'm assuming you didn't have loads of
experience in so like
what i don't know what comes up for you
when i say how how have you been willing
to take that first step or get out of
your
comfort zone do you think yeah that's a
good question
thank you um i think for me
i just really enjoy a challenge like
i want to come to work every day and
face a puzzle like i
i want it to be engaging i want to feel
like
i have to work it through and i have to
figure out how to make something happen
that not everyone else can do and i
think that that's
a really rewarding part about a job if
you can find it right and so
you know i similar to ali my role has
changed almost every year i've been in
the business thus far
or every two years um and i love that
i think it's absolutely pushed me and
challenged me to grow in ways that i
never would have been able to push
myself
um and i think that's ultimately why i
keep doing it and keep
taking it on no matter how unqualified i
think it may be or
how uh you know stressed it may make me
i think
i really want to push myself to be
the best that i can be and also to add
the most value that i can
to the people that i'm working with and
to the clients that we work with and
you know i think not to make this kind
of selling on faded but i think fade in
has really tied into that for me i think
the the passion i have to be a part of
something that's trying to do something
that's changing the industry that's
doing
it a different way that's letting us
kind of go out and and make it our own
is a huge part of what's in it for me
you know it's that i get to put my name
out the door and say this is my office
it's my team this is how we're doing it
and
and being able to integrate that with
such a great company that we have is is
awesome but
um how have i been able to jump and make
the leap every time
i think i've just forced myself um it's
always scary it's always overwhelming um
it's always been something i'm not 100
sure of
but i always come back to this final
question of like why not
like what do you really have to lose um
and and
it's a great question
because if it's not if it's not like i
don't know
might lose like i might lose the people
i care about or
i might not have not live or whatever
like it's what okay what else
why not then yeah should not mean that's
just perspective
yeah so as we come to the end here then
so you've obviously grown this this part
of the the business
what's been some of the the key
learnings so far then in
i guess maybe we can sort of think about
attracting
talent maybe think about sort of
uh yeah like hiring hiring people how
has that been has it been difficult
have you have you got a better
understanding when to hire like
obviously i'm sure you've heard this but
obviously it's just the most ironic
thing but most recruitment businesses
one of their main pain points i'd say
top five
is hiring for their own business so
what's been you what's been your journey
with that
any key learnings yeah i mean i've
learned a tremendous amount um
i think hiring was a huge part of it to
be honest i think
um if i could go back and do it
different i would have had a
better understanding of the local talent
pool and market
um from a new graduate perspective
um and i think i also would have really
taken a lot more time in initially
picking
who our first team was and that's not to
knock any of the guys we have we have
an incredible group of people down here
but i think um you know we've also had
people that haven't made it and i think
a lot of that came down to
me just not really putting my finger
accurately enough on what i needed
and the people that were going to really
launch this from nothing
you know that's an incredibly difficult
thing to do it's very mentally trying
um as probably anyone who's done it
would tell you so i think that was
something you know i learned the hard
way was to really dig in
a lot harder into as i said in the
beginning you know mindset
um of people and and focusing on hiring
people who understood
that this wasn't going to be easy that
it is hard that it is a challenge every
day and that
um you know they were doing it because
it was going to be worth it so i think
that was a learning point
um what i'll say i think
for me it's been really trying to find
the right balance
of being an incredibly driven
fast-paced motivated environment
for my employees and team to work in
with
having a bunch of fun and enjoying being
here every day um
and as easy as that might sound i think
that balance is tough
like i think you know one thing i'm glad
that fade in really does is people are
not a commodity for us we really invest
in the people
that we have we try to keep keep our
teams consistent not have a lot of
turnover and obviously i think we're
you know we've been pretty successful
with that here which has been great but
it is still you have those days where
you come in and the room feels really
tense or it feels really heavy or
there's just not the energy or the level
that you need going on you know and
you have to figure out what are those
motivators for the people that are
working there today you know
is it they just need to kind of let
loose and get some stress off and have a
little fun is that that they need a bit
of a kick in the ass and and need to
kind of get going and have someone push
them forward to wake up a little bit
like
and so i think i didn't really pay as
much attention to that in the beginning
as i probably should have and i think
it's something i'm really conscious of
now and will continue to be
as they move forward kind of growing the
business yeah it's really interesting
it's yeah like a balance of
have setting and having really high
standards
along with being mindful of the sort of
long-term culture that you want to
create
where people enjoy working there they
don't feel like just getting their balls
busted all the time like it's yeah
but also having high standards and
people knowing what they need if they
turn up today they're under the fade and
logo what's expected of them
right yeah that's interesting yeah and
then have you
and then have you only hired typically
chinese out of interest
no i have hired some experienced people
um and i have had a couple people
transfer
internally with some experience in the
business oh really okay
so just interesting point uh before we
finish you know
you said around i would have been a bit
more mindful around the local talent
that's actually something that has been
a bit of a learning when speaking to uk
businesses going into the u.s yeah and i
think sometimes it can be underestimated
i think the remote pieces obviously had
a positive impact on this or affected it
but
i spoke with quite a few uk recruiters
that then launched american parts of the
the business where i don't know it might
have started in boston and then realized
oh
[ __ ] like there's like there's not loads
of universities around here where we can
tap into
and the people around here are expecting
really high salaries we can't really
compete with that
what sort of things are of interest
obviously you're and
you grew up in america so you're going
to have even more insight to this but i
guess
when you say that what would you have
looked out for if you get what i mean to
that you think would have maybe
made it a bit more easier to attract or
have more access to
um yeah trainees yeah um
this probably isn't like the answer
you're looking for but honestly i i wish
i
would have done more interviews like i
wish i came down twice i did interview
you know kind of weeks and i think i
just should have spent more time doing
it than that at the time we were
incorporating a ton of virtual
interviewing into our process so this
was a couple of years ago
um if i could go back i would have done
a lot more virtually and then met the
people in person that you know i felt
like kind of
i needed to meet um but i think in terms
of
you know the local talent pool market or
what i would have looked at different
i think i've noticed and hiring out of a
lot of schools now you know there are
just
certain types of people that tend to
come out of certain universities or
areas or programs and
that is something that had i known
in hindsight i probably would have
targeted more people out of some of
those programs you know where we've seen
some of our most successful
employees come from um and i also think
just
probably spending more time with our
internal recruitment team to work on
undergraduate recruitment and to be at
their career fairs and to make our name
known
so we really were acquiring kind of that
top level of talent
um so i think those are probably two
things and lastly i think we did it at
the wrong time of year if i'm honest i
think if we were
um i think you need to you need to align
with make grads if you're bringing in
new grads
um i think it's if you're hiring people
in november or december
you know it's potentially going to be a
different group of people or people who
have struggled to get a job maybe before
that obviously not everyone i think we
did a good job of finding somewhere that
wasn't the case but
i've found it's a lot harder to hire on
that cycle than on a normal graduate
cycle
got it final sort of two questions
really before we finish
yeah interesting to hear this one what
would you say
sort of in in your team now and what
you're building what would you say this
sort of free non-negotiables that
everyone around you
have to live to from a sort of culture
perspective
that yeah what what are the sort of
things that they have to listen to the
three non-negotiables of your sort of
culture that you're building that
everyone
lives to do you think yeah um i think
one is we really push quite hard to be
better today than we were yesterday
um whether that is in the work that we
do
or the way that we contribute to the
team or the energy that we have or
whatever it is i think that's a huge
thing that we embody um be their first
phone call
is something we say a lot as well so
whether it is a candidate or a client or
a friend or a colleague internally how
do you make sure that you are the person
that when they are hiring or firing or
they need advice um
that they pick up the phone call yep
right um
and so i think those are you know those
are probably our two like biggest scores
i think if i were to pick a third really
we're just talking about work hard play
hard i think we really just try to
balance like
i'm a big believer that one of the main
reasons we lose
good talent and recruitment is burnout i
think that you have
to find a way to
maximize your time and efficiency during
the day and that you 100
can be a top biller and a top performer
within the normal working hours
i don't think that you have to be here
at 5 a.m and leaving at 10 p.m every
night
so we really try to push efficiency and
productivity throughout the day and
grind as hard as we possibly can and
then sort of pencils down and go have a
good time
um and i think that contributes to a
culture where a lot of people are really
close outside of work and enjoy
you know being with each other in and
out of the office which is you know a
huge part of the team
environment that you feel when you come
here brilliant yeah
absolutely love being the first call so
final question
what is the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career
that's a good question um
i don't know that i have an ultimate
goal i think
i think an ultimate goal for me ties
into just wanting to be a part of
something that matters
i think i want to feel like what i'm
doing every day has a tangible impact
i want to be a part of a company a
business a team
whether i'm growing it or or whatever it
may be
that is trying to do things their own
way
that is trying to kind of carve out
something and make it their own
um i i felt that from kind of the first
moment i joined this company and it was
a big part of the reason that i joined
i think they were setting out to kind of
do something that no one had done and
it was a very underdog mentality and and
that's how i want to continue to feel i
think i
i just want to always feel like we're
fighting up against that next level
of greatness and um yeah i don't know
what it'll feel like i guess exactly
when i
hit it or achieve it or when that would
be never when it's just
yeah it's just the journey yeah yeah
well well uh elissa thank you so much i
think you've
honestly i think there's been so much
gold in this episode you've
really done a great job in articulating
the answers when i've asked you and
everything but
yeah really excited to to see where you
are in another two years where the
business is
and thank you so much for for coming on
the podcast yeah you as well thanks so
much for having me it's been fun